you're part of the extreme microbiome
project
what does that evolve and what kind of
fun
fun organisms
have you learned about have you gotten
to explore we have a really fun project
xmp the extreme microbiome which is as
it sounds like we look for really odd
places like
heavy radiation environments high salt
high or low temperature you know strange
area the space station for example lots
of radiation in microgravity places
where organisms can evolve for
interesting adaptations and some of them
have been organisms we've seen like a
candy pink lake in australia called lake
hillier which would just publish a paper
on this word why is it pink uh so it's
actually uh denelia celina's these one
of these organisms there's a mixture of
bacteria
and some algae that are there that make
it bright pink so they actually make
carotenoids these like really sort of uh
orangey and kind of pink molecules when
you look at them in the light so if you
know if you get enough of the bacteria
it becomes pink so it's not just pink
it's like a bubble gum pink the lake and
so we uh that that's just an odd it's a
halophile being said it grows in 30 salt
and if you go below 10 15 percent salt
it doesn't even grow it actually kills
it
yeah there it is liqueur is it toxic to
humans or no it so when you walk in the
pink lake actually it's so hypertonic
meaning it's so salty you can feel it
lysing and killing your cells on your
foot so it actually hurts to walking
because it's so salty
uh so yeah so but it won't kill you
listen you have to suffer for art that's
right great art requires software i mean
so it is a beautiful lake uh you have to
get permits to go sample there but we
actually just got an email last week
there's pilots who fly over this in
australia because they love the color
yeah so he emailed us one of the pilots
and he said hey guys i saw you publish
his paper
it's not as pink as it used to be
because he loves flying over it and it
was like a little bit less pink because
i had a bunch of rain in the past few
weeks so it was just a little bit
diluted so we reassured him it'll get
more pink as they grow again uh but
basically yeah it's a beautiful pink
lake and so that is gorgeous
it's almost like it's like a dr seuss
book or something it doesn't it's like
it doesn't even look hard to get to yeah
there's no road you have to basically
fly uh land nearby and then paddle in
but so it's not next to anything
so it's hard to get to but once you get
there um it's beautiful if anyone knows
how to get there let me know i want to
go there okay cool what are some other
extreme organisms
that you study other ones uh there's
some organisms we studied in the space
station called acinitobacter pitii which
is a
often found in human skin but we found
hundreds of strains in the space jason
that we've brought down and curated and
then sequenced uh and this is with uh
katsuri venkatsuran who's at jet
propulsion laboratory working with him
and they have evolved so they're now
they no longer look like any earth-based
ascii bacter they don't look like
they've now basically a new species so
actually we uh there's there's a
different species of bacteria and fungi
that have now mutated so much on the
space station they're
literally a new species and so we've
found some of those that have just
they're they're evolving in life is
always evolving and we can see it also
in the space entirely new species born
in the space yeah that's completely
different so we we found one species
actually um
that we named after a donor to cornell
someone who's donated funds to research
so he named a different species of
fungus after him naganeshia tolchinsky
because he's igor tolchinsky so as a
thank you for him donating to cornell we
said we've named this fungus that we
found on the space station for you was
he uh grateful or did he stop funding
research
very grateful and then and i told them i
said if you have like an ex-girlfriend
we could try and name like a uh you know
a genital fungus after her or something
if you want and he said yeah he said
maybe
he stopped answering after that
okay what about like in extreme
conditions um
in ice
in heat is that something of interest to
you and the things that survive
where most things can't yes
of keen interest i think that will be
the road map for some of the potential
adaptations what we could think of for
human cells or certainly for
our human the microbiome like they're
just all the micro organisms in and on
and around us
so we've seen you know even there's this
one crater it's called um the the lake
of fire it's in turkmenistan where it's
been on fire because of oil that have
been set on fire decades ago and it's
still burning so we collected some
samples from there and those were some
pseudomonas potatoes some species we
found there that can so there's stuff
alive there it seems to be surviving
there
by this large uh pit of fire oh yeah
there is the desert it's been just on
fire for decades apparently
so this
is though it's just the lake of fire
yeah yeah and it's that they said soviet
scientists had set up a drilling rig
here for extraction of natural gas
of course it would be in this part of
the world that you would get something
like this but the rig collapsed and
methane gas is being released from the
crater
yeah so for those just listening we're
looking at a
at a lake
full of fire and there's something alive
there
allegedly and pseudometers are known to
be some of the most tough organs they
actually can clean toxic waste
from you know many years of superfund
sites where there's so much waste that's
been deposited you'll find them there as
well actually there's one place in the
gowanus canal there's something it's
called
in new york city in brooklyn
and it is a complete toxic waste dump
that was where a lot of waste in the
1700s was dumped and so the gateway to
hell um is what it's called but the
the nickname
[Laughter]
so the the gowanus canal is also a place
that has been fun to sequence and see so
the pseudomonas species that can survive
that basically pulling toxins from the
environment so
it is if you create this toxic landscape
and then evolution comes in and says
fine i'll make things that can survive
here and when you look at the
biochemistry of those species
what they've created is their own
salvation basically the selection has
made them survivors and suddenly you can
use that to remediate other polluted
sites for example so that explains
twitter perfectly the toxicity creature
adaptation
for the for the uh
psychological microbiome that is social
media